this video is sponsored by brilliant
more on that later hey what's up guys my
name is jonah welcome back to the code
review series everyone's favorite series
that you have all missed over the last
like month or two those of you who don't
know this is a series where you guys
send me all of your suspicious code and
i take a look at it it's honestly
amazing that i haven't like gotten all
my files deleted yet so last time we
took a look at a ray tracer in c plus
plus and made it a whole lot faster i'll
have that video linked up there so you
can check it out today we're going to
step away a little bit from the ray
traces uh i know a lot of you are really
interested in that and there'll be more
on that coming later but today i thought
we would take a look at this so griffin
thompson has sent us gar engine an
engine in c sharp who would have thought
we'd be taking a look at c sharp on this
channel so gar engine very interesting
name uh
he's an engine i'm running in c-sharp to
learn about how opengl works and to
eventually get a career i'm currently 16
studying computer science in my spare
time just recently i implemented shadows
screw shadow mapping yeah it can be
definitely difficult it's your first
time i hope you can give me some
expertise in game engine design or an
engine design since i'm new to the doing
this kind of work although it is written
in c sharp i think you can compare it to
station plus plus well we'll see about
that i like that this person has
included a screenshot pro tip if you're
trying to actually get me to review code
is try and make it as interesting as
possible and here is a github repository
link let's take a look so it seems like
this takes me to like some subfolder
called g e silk
okay cool so this is it c sharp engine
features directional shadows sudo pbr
sao bloom ibl ecs render frame buffers
this looks pretty
pretty well developed now this being a
c-sharp engine i mean it comes with a
solution file i'm not sure how this is
going to work for people not running
windows my plan is obviously just going
to be to open this in visual studio
let's go ahead and clone it into a
directory i always do a recursive clone
just in case
what's up
can you come over and help me traverse
this bioentry
hang on man i'm just recording a video
look
i can't do this and i need your help can
you just come over and do this for me
just like look it up online watch a
video or something i already have i've
watched all the videos on bioretreats
and i still don't get it have you tried
brilliant what's that is that one of
those course websites well kind of but
like they actually have practical
examples they ask you questions they
quiz you all about stuff so you actually
learn the content and remember it huh
that sounds great tell me more brilliant
is a website filled with courses on stem
topics but the thing that separates them
from a lot of other similar websites is
that they are all about learning
interactively these courses do not just
push videos into you and then it's up to
you to do literally the rest they are
interactive as you can see they have a
lot of computer science related topics
that i think will be really interesting
to you guys so if we actually do take a
look at binary trees brilliant does
really well at like presenting you with
some information showing you some
diagrams and then asking you questions
about it which you have to answer the
reason why i love this is because most
people learn by doing most people learn
through practical means if you're just
taking in a lot of theory
that is pretty much useless you need
that practical experience and brilliant
is brilliant at providing you with that
aside from learning a wide range of
computer science specific topics as i
mentioned they do have a lot of math and
actually if we take a look at the
computer science algorithms you'll see
they also have some neural network
content which i'm actually going to go
through these courses have really clear
intuitive explanations and they're
suitable for all skill levels and their
courses are actually quite fun tim and i
actually went through the binary search
course earlier today and it kept us
engaged the whole way through so go
ahead and visit brilliant using the link
in the description below you can get
started as i mentioned for free but
brilliant also has a special offer the
first 200 of you who do sign up for an
annual membership using the link in
description below will receive 20 off go
ahead and give it a go i genuinely think
a lot of you will find it extremely
helpful and it will teach you lots huge
thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video alright so once that has all
completed gar engine public let's go
ahead and just open that directory and
we'll see what we've got solution let's
open that yeah i'm kind of excited to
take a look at this looks nicely
organized here program.cs i assume is
the entry point static void main nice
and clean that's what i like to see so
it looks like there's two projects here
ges j guess
silk and gar engine
they both look suspiciously similar this
one's a start-up project let's go ahead
and run this although i'd remember that
he did point to
this one in the email so i'm i think
maybe this is different but let's just
go ahead and start this up and we'll see
what happens okay so it's on my other
monitor here it is this is what it looks
like looks like we have
a skybox we have a 3d model with some
kind of like
specular reflection over here we have
some transparency in the leaves which is
cool
uh and over here this looks like part of
sponsor actually and we have the
archways
i'm not really seeing any shadows or
anything of use here um there is also a
console window that opened
and let's see if we can resize that and
take a look at what this is saying
okay stuff is happening
that must be the frame time interesting
now i want to take a look at
the other one as well because that's
that is the one that he linked in
fairness okay here we go
so this seems to have
a shadow and otherwise looks the same
it's got a nice uh
skybox can't tell if the bloom is coming
in or not
does that look gloomy to you guys
maybe like a little bit
he did say he had bloom though
and
i'm trying to look for the ssio as well
which i'm i guess that could be sso
it's really hard to tell especially
because this thing is spinning but i
mean yeah it looks like a an interesting
engine um
it's running at vsync over here for me
uh and where when we just run a debug
build as well so
let's dig into this and see what we can
say about the code so the first thing is
the entry point right really simple now
i wanna a quick disclaimer here i
uh i do know c sharp but i'm not like i
wouldn't call myself a c sharp expert
um
i'm obviously more of like a c plus plus
programmer i work on game engines c
sharp is something that i more or less
use for scripting and for games now back
when i worked at ea i did a fair amount
of tools programming so basically worked
on like the
like editor as well and a lot of ea's
tools not just like the frostbite
ecosystem but also other tools are
written in c sharp and i did kind of
write a bunch of them as well so i have
quite a lot of c sharp experience but
definitely not as much as c boss plus
and as i mentioned most of it these days
like since i left ea has been like you
know writing games like in hazel because
hazel uses c sharp for scripting as well
so uh it's going to be interesting to me
to take a look at this and see what i
can say and in general do you guys want
to see more c sharp if you do let me
know in the comment section below
because otherwise like i've been
somewhat selecting c or c plus plus code
reviews most of the time okay so public
starter class program with a private
static window now this question mark if
i am not mistaken means that it is an
optional
now why but this is a class so
what does that even mean
this is awkward i don't even know what
this means
so so from my ultra quick google search
it
is a nullable type as i thought but it's
a class classes are already nullable
types
i'm just not sure why you need this in
this case because
can't you just
like you know
a non-nullable field window what
but it's a class prior to c-sharp 8 all
reference types were nullable
so they've changed this now nullable
reference type professional group
officials introduced it earlier you know
the likelihood of your code caused the
runtime to throw and i'll reference
exception you can use annotations that
can declare whether a variable is a
nullable reference type or a
non-nullable reference type so a
reference isn't supposed to be null so
they have made it so that if something
can be null and null is a valid value
for something
then you have to use a question mark and
then you can use like
the null forgiving operator what is all
of this following a variable named to
force the null state to be not null
for example if you know the name
variable isn't null but the compiler
says wanting you can write this
to overwrite the compiler's analysis
i see
so if i understand this correctly
the compiler wants us to be like no no
you have to basically
tell me that like you know what you're
doing by specifying question mark to be
to make this now nullable so that i
don't give you warnings even though i'm
sure this code would execute fine right
it's just the danger of this code and it
keeps popping up on my other monitor
because this isn't my main display but
um
because i guess the problem is that it
sees this as a potential
pitfall right because if you were to
execute this code then of course it
would
crash
because window is null and you're trying
to de-reference like a null pointer here
to call the run function on it
right and it would be obviously upset at
this there's your null reference
exception in a very blurry fashion
however
if you do this then well like again that
doesn't really
change the behavior does it but the idea
is you could maybe do a question mark
dot run or whatever in which case it
just would not run the run function
since window is null or you can be like
no
it's definitely there in which case of
course it would crash because you just
lied to it so i still don't really
understand the purpose of this other
than like
just maybe
some kind of
like what is this this is supposed to be
some kind of annotation for the compiler
to get rid of that warning because
you're like
it's nullible so therefore as the
programmer i'm allowing it to be null
but that's weird because that's that's
not really how my brain works in my
brain let's talk about my brain for a
second
in my brain
this is a class so therefore it already
is implicitly this whole question mark
thing
right whereas whereas in the past you
know what this was used for is if you
have like a struct in c sharp structs
are not nullable so there's no way you
could do something like this like that
just is not code that would compile
right because it's not nullable so what
do you do well you can make this
specifically a nullable variable right
so the type is nullable now and you can
have null just like you can with like an
integer where if it's you can assign it
to something or you can keep it
as null like this but obviously an int
can't be assigned null to if it's just
like that so i guess they've extended
this to classes now i seriously did not
know that let's change the name of the
series real quick not code review but
rather channel learns c sharp i did not
know this this is apparently classes are
like not apparently classes what this
guy had was he had a question mark here
right and
uh the reason he has this is because
this obviously initially is null right
like he didn't create something and so
these days apparently c sharp is not
happy with you if you remove this
because even though it's a class like
this isn't a struct or something that
isn't nullable like it's a class still
that can be assigned null
but still it's like whoa now like are
you sure
that's what you want and if you are sure
then apparently you're supposed to use
question marks everywhere to basically
indicate to the compiler that your
class like that null is an okay value
for this variable to be okay that's wild
anyway let's get back to the code review
this is
this is why i stick to c plus plus so we
initialize the window class over here
which just sets up some variables and
like there's a bunch of boilerplate
stuff here that no one probably cares
about and then we run run i'm assuming
sets up okay so it sets up some
functions here to call so these are
basically just like events so globe
globals okay i love my globals class
global's window and then load uh and
these are all like actions which are
just yeah so we have our events here
that we can call oh we can basically add
functions too so that when that event is
raised it calls on load
uh another good feature of c sharp is
obviously that whole like event system
that they have on update and render so
we basically set all of these up now
global's window and window is a game
window so we have two different kind of
window classes i guess we've got a
window and then we've got something
called a game window which is i'm
assuming the game window is more or less
like the application like what
i would call the application class in
hazel i can't even find it anywhere
globals uh globals contains a game
window so where is the game window
oh hang on
oh that's an open tk thing
okay
all right okay so game window is an open
tk thing which by the way for those of
you don't know open tk is like uh
something it's like a library that
allows you to
use opengl inside c sharp it's kind of
like lwjgl for java i guess
it's very similar to that
and i'm not sure if it includes yeah so
it includes a mathematics library as
well which is quite useful so if you
want to use like opengl and c sharp for
some reason then you can do so using
open tk alright global's window run so
that just calls that function and i
guess this is probably something that
like
is inside open dk and that yeah
initializes the up update thread and
that's like kind of the game loop oh
here's all the code
um and then yeah then we get our kind of
while loop right and you can see it
actually internally uses gel of w so
this is all kind of very similar to like
a normal c plus plus architecture that
those of you who watch my channel are
probably aware about um but this is all
happening kind of in c sharp and it's
basically using those libraries and it's
got those bindings so it can call back
into the c plus plus code of like gfw
and whatever opengl like wrapper it's
using um to actually execute that code
okay so the rest of all of this now this
person i think in their email wanted
some feedback
on like the
engine design
right and they are 16 like 16 is is
definitely very young i started
programming when i was 16. like 16 was
like when i wrote my first line of code
um so we'll try it we'll try our best
here to kind of give some insight into
what's going on but basically like okay
so when i'm looking at stuff i like to
collapse everything
control ml is what i use there uh to
just it's like a little chord so ctrl m
and then you keep holding ctrl and then
you press l uh and then you get into
like this view where it just collapses
absolutely everything from here i like
to um and this is like
this is like the kind of
probably the best raw visual studio way
of doing this i think and it's also very
fast as you can see if you've got visual
assist you can just press alt m and it
will show you like all of the functions
but this i find gives you a really nice
overview of the class so you can see
like immediately what we've got here and
when i'm looking through code especially
architecturally i like to kind of
collapse everything so that i can get
like an overview of the code now if
you're really fancy um i i don't know
why i thought of this but visual studio
actually has some tools uh especially if
you're using c sharp something that's
like a managed language and visual
studio supports a lot of really kind of
deep stuff with c sharp that it just
doesn't with c plus plus because z plus
is very complicated it's compiled and
all of that whereas c sharp is like a
managed language and like there's just a
lot more kind of introspection and like
reflection and a lot of stuff that it
can do with language a lot easier than
with c plus so basically they have
better tools is what i'm trying to say
for it um that's why they have like this
one reference and stuff and you can see
where it's called from like immediately
like just the way that the compiler
integrates with all of this uh kind of
intellisense stuff is way better than c
plus plus and so because of that i think
they even have some tools where you can
get like a a class overview or something
and it will show you let me see if i can
find that okay well it turns out what
i'm thinking of is actually like
something that you have to add but you
can have like a class designer thing
anyway the point is there's ways for
like i'm pretty sure there's waze i'm
not sure if it's like a visual studio
community feature that might be like an
enterprise or a pro level feature but
you can basically like get visual studio
to generate like a uml diagram or
something so you can get like a nice
overview of your project i've actually
done that before when i was working in
ea like ages ago or something i just
wanted like a die a huge diagram like a
print and like a2 of just like what is
going on here because everything was so
complicated at certain certain points
but anyway point is um if you're like
aside from those kind of features you
know you can always just collapse
everything like this and then you can
easily see what's going on here so this
is my window class and it's got all of
this like all of these kind of member
variables and then it's got all of these
functions so let's kind of go through
this and think about the architecture
mostly and that's what we'll kind of
focus on in today's code review so first
of all um
you know we have these underscores now
this is basically the equivalent of i
don't know what i did there basically
the equivalent of uh like m underscore
you know that kind of stuff in c plus
plus now the reason why it's actually
kind of uh written like this here and
this is a very common pattern for c
sharp programs as well is because you
can start your variable names with
underscores which is not something you
can do in c plus plus so in c plus
because that's not allowed in c sharp a
lot of people tend to just do this now i
still in my c sharp code like to do m
underscore the reason why is it not only
points to the fact that it's a private
member variable like you would expect
but if something is static or constant
right so if i had like a const or if i
had a static
right then i can differentiate that by
using s and c if i really want to i
don't really use c very often but s is
something i like to have right so uh
because of that i still like to use that
but just if you notice a lot of that in
c sharp code it's because like that's
kind of a common convention that i've
seen a lot of as well so the window
class to me obviously is supposed to be
something that represents more or less
like your game window right so i would
use like the window class in hazel
actually might be nice to compare this
to like some of hazel's code so if we
take a look at like windows window which
is like the window obviously this is c
plus plus but if we take a look at this
class inside hazel and i'll actually
have to bring up the
header file you can see what kind of
stuff it contains right it basically
contains like a glfw window and it
contains uh everything around that right
so init will probably like you know
create a window set the details you know
initialize error callbacks and all of
that stuff create like a graphics
context and a swap chain and everything
so that we can actually render stuff and
then set up like all of the events uh so
my point is that window classes
typically obviously contain only stuff
crucial to like the actual window so
that you can get that set up and running
this class contains
uh you know stuff as kind of far down as
bloom settings so to me that's a little
bit too much now the thing is i know
that you're using opentk and opentk
uh opentk like you know it obviously has
like its own wrapper for basically all
of this like the whole game loop is in
opentk right there's no loop here even
um i mean there's not a loop in my
window class as well in hazel because we
would be we that that's inside
application application is something
that kind of uh you know application
owns a window and then that's kind of
the main window you can have sub windows
but that's like the main window that's
inside the application class and the
application class contains that main
loop and all of that and it handles like
everything it needs to like everything
stems from that class basically now uh
this like that's why this almost looks
to me like an application class that
just happens to contain
like a window
although i know that like technically
speaking like when you call run you know
your windows contain inside globals so
i don't really like this architecture
because again you're just making
everything static now i know that you're
16 and i know that when i was 16 this is
what i did as well right so this is like
this is
fine you know um you'll probably
probably won't write code like this
forever
my solution to everything back then was
to just make stuff static why because
like i was using java back then um so
it's kind of similar to c sharp i guess
uh but i like i didn't quite understand
like object-oriented programming and how
like objects relate to each other like
what instances are like all of that
stuff like that didn't really click with
me until probably a few months like or
even a year after i started programming
so in the beginning like in the first
few months i was just like i have a
variable i want that to be accessible in
another place in my code how do i
achieve that what's like the the most
kind of the like the path of least
resistance and usually it was just make
the variable static right because if you
make the variable static then of course
you can access it everywhere in your
code base now obviously that's not
always correct not to say that it's
wrong like you know
certain things can be static obviously
but architecturally speaking it's not
always like a good thing to do
which is why i like i mean i wouldn't
set up anything like this as well load
update frame render frame and mouse move
are all things that can just be owned
within this window class like i'm not
really sure why this has to be in a
global thing uh like it i don't see
like this window um you know which is
the open tk window i feel like that
should just reside within this window
itself
or inside this class but you could call
the class application and everything
could stem could stem from there and
then if you wanted to access it instead
of making like a static class like
globals you could obviously like because
you only expect to have one application
you could actually make this like a
singleton so you could have something
like public application you know
get or whatever or get app and then that
could just basically return your kind of
s instance which would be your like you
know
private static application s instance um
that you would kind of initialize when
you first like make your application so
that's actually kind of similar
to how hazel does it for reference if we
look at hazel's application header file
over here then you can see that we have
this static application s instance and
then we have a function called get here
which just basically just dereferences
the pointer and returns a reference to
this kind of given application class why
because that's something that like
obviously you know you only have one
instance of the application that's kind
of your core so it's fine to have this
and this is where like people who start
talking about singletons and like how
bad they are like
they have their place uh and
you know there are obviously like stuff
or maybe just call this i don't even
know what you would call this in c sharp
because you don't really need to get as
you can just use properties you don't
get a like functions but anyway the
point is um
it's fine you know you need stuff like
this sometimes because how else are you
gonna do it you're not gonna design some
convoluted weird thing that has to like
stem down from like one point in your
code base you want this to be global and
accessible everywhere because that's
totally okay
anyway getting on with this so yeah so
we run this uh and then let's so we were
looking at this class let's kind of get
back to that so we have on mouse move
which is like so again these are just
like events right and you can see it
goes right into the camera system so
again what i would do is you have a lot
of stuff here already like why is the
camera system not here i feel like the
camera system is in here because the
camera system like which is a uh an
internal class
inside one inside camera so actually
hang on so and then this is a static
function update mouse
um
okay
just wondering how deep to get into this
because it's like it's almost difficult
to give good suggestions without
rewriting like a lot of this and kind of
walking through
why
uh you know how i would kind of organize
this architecture but i'll try my best
so camera system like camera system has
just one function in it um
called and it's uh
okay so you have a base system base
class because that's something uh has a
template argument or a generic argument
of t where t has to be a component so
base system is something that has is a
system that contains a list of
components of a particular type
so camera system uh is a base system
that has basically camera components
right so this contains a whole bunch of
uh well it's a system so that makes
sense right so the idea obviously with
the ecs and this actually looks like
it's fairly well implemented which is
good to see
is this is a particular system that has
a list of components which it actually
seems to own
um which is interesting i mean it's more
or less
a correct ecs though so you have an
array of tile apache components and then
what you do is you go through and you
update all of those components in one go
right now there are specific things here
that apply to
certain components for example you're
going to go through all of your
components and update them with whether
or not they're in shadow which is a bit
you know
presumptuous of why like why components
would care about the hat but basically
camera system is just a system
which will go through every single
camera in the scene and do all of this
stuff to it which i guess kind of makes
sense because update camera is going to
be called from within window when you
basically move the mouse well it's
actually called update mouse
wait that's in base system hold your
horses so camera system update mount
right okay so camera system update mouse
will actually
uh call this super
sorry call this base method
which will do component update mouse
okay never mind because i thought update
coupled it's the same thing it's just i
messed up my functions so update mouse
will call the update mouse um
function inside
the camera class so the camera class
will have an update mouse function here
it is and that but the thing is because
it's wrapped inside a system this will
happen for every camera in the scene
right so it's kind of a clever way to
obviously structure everything and it's
good because
you're kind of uh thinking in that kind
of ecs way the ecs mentality where
instead of having like you know entities
packed together in an array and then for
each entity you go through every entity
one by one and you like check to see if
it has a camera and if so update the
camera you kind of do all the cameras in
one go you kind of batch together
everything that's related so all of like
all of each component kind of gets
processed in one go and that's really
good that's basically um
that's that's a really big step for
optimization
because what you're trying to do is
you're trying to work on memory that's
kind of related and tightly packed
all in one go before moving on to a
different block of memory rather than
being all scattered and we can talk a
lot more about that um and like the
importance of the cpu cache and all that
in the future
but that's kind of good to see okay good
so that's kind of that function let's go
back to the window class
okay and then then we just have random
stuff like a low up in here so you know
put this and put this in like a math
file because this is obviously like a
mathematical function um so there's no
need for it to kind of be in here uh and
then we have unload which is so where
does that
on load is that something that we we
patch in here so when the window decides
to load so that's why we have all of
these events because these are all like
this is a game window inside open dk and
it needs to basically call back into
client code so it sets up events that
you can hook into so that it for example
inside its um its own
uh while loop its own kind of uh game
loop it will actually call into your
code so dispatch update frame for
example will probably actually call you
know on update frame
uh which will probably call this update
frame invoke with the arguments and
update frame is that action that we
patched into so we'll call our on update
function so architecturally that's kind
of how it all patches together and again
that will update the camera system and
then go into globals if uh you press the
escape key it will close okay cool
so we basically have like an idea of all
of this now one thing i'm noticing here
as well so when you do the onload most
of the stuff that you're setting up here
is obviously to do with the render up so
you're creating textures you're creating
render buffers you're doing all of this
stuff uh which render buffers uh okay
that's your own class we'll get into
that in a minute but basically this is
all stuff that obviously uh i would
expect to find inside a renderer so it's
really important because again this is
an engine right this isn't just like a
graphics thing it's really important to
separate graphics and rendering a little
bit from your core kind of engine and
the rest of the engine systems so the
main window class that handles like what
looks like the main game loop and all of
that shouldn't be directly tied to like
rendering anything really i would expect
this to be in a class called renderer
and for it to be completely separate
because aside from just crowding this
class and making it like a little bit
hard to read and just a bit messy
it also kind of means that you're more
or less limiting yourself to having just
one of these
and you know oh why would i want to have
more than one renderer well you might
want to have more than one viewport as
an example or maybe you want to
maybe there's a need to set up a
renderer that renders like something
else so as an example like in hazel we
can have a game view and we can have a
scene view those kind of uh and we can
have multiple viewports as well but my
point is when we set up like a like the
the scene that is being played versus
the scene that is just being edited
because they are physically different
scenes when we hit play we make a copy
of the edited scene so that we can play
and you know do whatever we want in
there without actually affecting the
original editor copy we said we set up a
whole new scene renderer for that so
that again like apart from being able to
switch between the two with no problem
it can kind of exist in its own little
sandbox and that's like i think that's a
really important architecture to have so
i would definitely kind of bring this
out um but otherwise let's take a look
at what you're doing here so you're
creating random buffers and render
textures so these are just opengl this
is just an opengl texture so you've
written this is your code right you've
written a class here that is an opengl
texture it will create a texture of a
given format it registers it with the
asset manager which basically i guess
just means that it adds it somewhere
what does register actually do
components add assets so asset is a
component
oh list so asset managers has a list of
assets but you've called it components
because you've copied and pasted this
from elsewhere so call this like assets
or something but basically yeah you just
have a list of assets so it's not
not much of an asset manager but it it's
a good start yeah then we just standard
opengl boilerplate um obviously there
are specific things here like such as
like shadow so it does this stuff
specifically for shadows because we need
uh
specific like texture comparison modes
and whatever but other than that it yeah
just allocate some memory on the gpu and
um
store nothing in the texture and we have
a blank texture that we can use bind to
buffer and all that stuff and use will
bind the image texture i probably won't
talk too much about render api
architecture
i'm planning to actually make a video
about that where i'll talk about like
how i like to write classes like this
because the way that i used to write
them and the way that i write that i
write them now has changed like
significantly
and we can also use kind of hazel as a
case study for that so i won't talk too
much about opengl and gpu kind of stuff
at the moment but uh this is fine like
there's nothing too wrong with this
um and then render buffer obviously does
the same thing basically but we actually
create frame buffers and then we can
have look like multiple uh multiple
render attachments here so that we can
basically um draw the model more than
one buffer at once which is good nice
and modern
um and then
yeah we have specific stuff here like
set shadow buffer which obviously like
you never really want to have stuff like
that you want it to be kind of like
um if i had to mention something about
this architecture this is stuff that the
renderer should do not stuff that you
should do inside like the render buffer
class so as an example i wouldn't have
this code here with a function called
set shadow buffer if you had a renderer
class you would have a shadow pass and
when you do a shadow pass and it's time
to bind the specific shadow like render
buffer then you would bind it in like
the specific way you want it but again
that's inside the renderer and that's
really important i think because that
means that the renderer kind of has
the authority to like use the data as it
wants because it's the thing that is
facilitating shadow passes and shadow
rendering in the first place not the
render buffer class like what does that
know about anything right render buffer
is just supposed to be a container of
data it's supposed to be a buffer of a
data that we can either write to or read
from right that's it whereas the
renderer is the big boy actually using
that for good um and so that's
that's something that i would definitely
like consider in terms of like an
architecture point of view is set up a
render class and just do everything in
the renderer like all the actual
rendering code should happen in the
renderer and then these classes are
basically just little um utility classes
that just basically will you know create
like you know this stuff they'll create
your actual frame buffers where you're
creating your frame buffer framework
buffer render buffer here and then
render buffer storage i guess
that will it'll allocate memory to
create your frame buffers and all that
stuff and maybe keep track of metadata
like width and height and resize them
and do whatever so it's a utility class
but the actual like i now want to
actually render some graphics or use
this practically that part you would
basically do inside uh your renderer
class so that's basically the biggest
thing i'm noticing here other than that
so we go through we load like shaders
i'm not going to look too much about
this stuff we have a skybox so how do we
load the skybox so get mesh from file is
skybox and then the textures
uh over here right base path for cubemap
paths
oh okay so
where is the resources resources
cube map oh okay
ah that's interesting okay so
it looks like we're loading our cube map
faces separately so there's a few things
wrong with this um first of all uh
splitting this up into six different
files and loading it is incredibly
inconvenient there's a readme here
ah okay hummus dot name
that's a trendy here we go so yeah so
this kind of stuff this is obviously
like this is what we call a horizontal
cross so
this is a fairly standard q map format
now you've looks like you've downloaded
this and then split it up into all of
these images or maybe i don't know maybe
he's
like the website downloads it like that
i don't know but generally like it's
good to
try and uh you know not load six
different images just because as you
probably noticed in your code it's a bit
of a pain having to go through where was
i inside the window class right having
to go through and create like six
different paths and append all of this
and then load all of that like that's a
nightmare i know this because i've done
it before and in fact um reading it from
a cute from a map like this can also be
a bit of a nightmare in hazel we kind of
do things differently we load an echo
rectangular image and then we make a
cube amp out of it now the second thing
is this an issue
is uh these are jpegs right and these
are 24 bit bit kind of images you
definitely want to upgrade to an hdr
pipeline and you want to take this kind
of in as an hdr image now again this
might just be given to you in a jpeg but
in general oops i moved that
in general obviously we want to kind of
deal with like a 16 32 bit per channel
so that we can actually set the exposure
from within our engine rather than
having to kind of bake the exposure into
one like level of exposure like this
which is more or less what happens when
you you know just use jpeg so
that would be my advice with that
section definitely switch to using.hdrs
and then either
and like you know in that horizontal
cross format so it's one file it's easy
to deal with or you can if you're
feeling very adventurous you can write
something that converts in a rectangular
image which is more widely available uh
in my experience and then it converts
into a cube map internally and all that
stuff just using compute shaders all
right so we do all the skybox stuff um
and then we have yeah like so the skybox
will have something like a material
component which probably provides a way
like this material component probably
provides a way for it to get rendered
right so kind of like sets a look for it
so that we can set like certain uniforms
so materials are generally just like a
shader and then it's uniform data and
like any textures and resources it might
have so that looks like basically what
you've got here you have some shader
settings it doesn't look like there are
and a shader obviously it doesn't look
like there are any textures associated
with
this maybe that's just not something you
have although i did see a rendered
texture okay and then we have a model
renderer component as well which
probably just
renders something the only thing that i
don't like about this stuff is that
obviously like setting up setting up
your renderer to be like inside an ecs
to me it's not there's not enough
context like model renderer like
you know if that's a component like why
is that a component because like yeah
it's got it's well i guess that's not
the actual renderer the system does
nothing
wait model renderer
so my render is the component my point
is you know when you do something like a
mesh render
which is i assume we're eventually going
to get to the code that actually does gl
draw elements which does the actual draw
call right this well this in this case
this is inside a vertex array but the
point is what you end up with when you
set up your kind of rendering code like
this is everything is massively
fragmented right i don't actually get to
see how something gets rendered i have
to go through all these different
classes and not only that but when you
get into more advanced rendering you'll
quickly realize that hang on a minute i
need more control over what is going on
because a lot of render passes are very
different from each other right and so
you basically wind up with this very bad
architecture where you need to like you
know make a you need to make a bunch of
functions inside vertex array to draw
all of your different things or inside
your model class and it's just all weird
and so that's why again i say no to all
of that you just have a renderer class
and that just does all the rendering for
you again you want to do the gel draw
elements you do that inside the renderer
class directly right instead of having
to set up this object oriented thing
where it just goes um very deep now
i'm beginning to think it might be
useful for me to make like just one
30 to 60 minute video that just shows
this architecture in a very simple
opengl kind of fashion
um let me know if you guys want to see
that in the comments below because that
would explain all this a lot more uh
rather than just me kind of talking and
trying to do stuff with my hands as if
that's helping so uh yeah i i might do
that um anyway let's kind of start
wrapping this up by taking a look at the
actual render passes now you don't have
much of an engine obviously here it's
mostly just a renderer so there's not
there's not a lot of stuff i can look at
if i just quickly go through the files i
don't think there's
there's much going on here
um you know a lot of these are again
using that component system of yours
uh which is like it's
you're going down the right track but
there's still a lot of stuff that needs
to be kind of improved there
um camera debug
okay so we have like all these different
textures
which are just like so we have an
interface with the texture or an
abstract class same kind of thing um but
we've got a bunch of functions static
functions here as well and all that
stuff to handle like texture utilities
all very standard you've even got a
noise texture here that kind of
generates some random pixels which is
cool
um
uh bloom settings
uh we'll look at bloom in a minute
compute oh compute
i wonder what you're doing with compute
take a look in a minute
and then material system
and these are just settings like to set
i guess for
um your material uniforms yeah so this
this is just a renderer so let's go and
actually take a look at the render
passes and i think we'll probably be
done with this so window
on render so let's see what we do so
if time is greater than 12 times zero
okay
sure
what do we even do with time does time
get incremented by
like delta time or something sure so
what every 12 seconds we look
okay um
so we've got the rotation of some entity
see this is like this is what i'm
talking about like what on earth so we
have
and see inside window you've got your
whole scene so you need you need you
also really desperately need like the
concept of a scene right you need to be
able to actually organize all of the
data that actually exists within
something in something you also don't
because of that like the biggest problem
i'm noticing here is you don't exactly
seem to have a container for entities
now when you create an entity
and you add components to it so
this has a read-only list of components
as well
and add component adds
to there but it also adds to itself
and then i guess the system will go
through and actually render it or
something so whenever you're kind of
lost with stuff like this by the way a
good uh way to go is to just if like we
know that the draw call happens here for
the vertex array right and so because it
happens here if we just put a breakpoint
here and just hit f5
like we know that we're going to end up
there
um and then from here we can obviously
take a look at the call stack so when
you're reading code that's a very
helpful thing so if we go over here we
know so we have on render which comes in
from
a model renderer system which happens on
render so there it is so we have that
model render system as i was uh
suspecting
that calls um
the base system which goes through every
single component
uh with that kind of shadow thing and
then uh update
will basically call mesh render which
we'll call like mesh data which is that
vertex array render and then that kind
of gets us here right so that's kind of
how we go through and render everything
and again like to me like model renderer
or whatever like you know you'd be
submitting meshes or something and then
that would do all of the rendering
within the renderer rather than kind of
going through the ecs so deeply and then
winding up inside vertex array and then
that does the actual rendering which is
like that's a very common way to set
stuff up but it's just very kind of far
from what i would call ideal and
especially like it just does not scale
well that's for sure um okay anyway so
render buffer the reddit bind update
render
uh all that stuff's fine so okay so i'm
a little bit interested in how you do um
so what's cube manager update need to do
it's so difficult to read any of this
just because
so what is this cube map renderer
and then that has an update so that just
does mesh render
material component okay so that maybe
that's what renders like the backdrop or
something and then we have render bloom
uh so we do program use params a lot of
mode you texture you bloom texture
dispatch
and then
current map okay so we go through all
the mips and
we dispatch a computer to okay so using
compute bloom
first up sample okay this actually looks
very similar to hazel's bloom code
let's take a look at the shader so
shader
bloom.shader
this is like this is my code
this is like exactly the same as hey
this is actually i wrote this code
thanks sam for the help with this method
of bloom
whoa okay let's back up a little bit
let's just do a quick diff with hazel's
code i'm serious this is like exactly
the same okay so this is this is this is
the the bloom shader and this is hazel's
bloom shader compare
lol
what okay so let's take a look at what's
different here so
i'm using 32 they're using 16 that's the
difference in that line
push constants because it's vulcan
this is literally my code but it's just
been like slightly changed a little bit
this stuff which like again i didn't
invent like
box down sampling 13 taps but i did
write this exact code these are my
comments like all of this stuff and the
way that i laid it out that's all that's
all me obviously you can tell it's like
identical
um what else
this stuff again is only different
because the names have been changed
wow
well i'm sure that i'm sure glad you got
sam to help you out with this now i'm
not 100 sure if we if like if sam is the
problem or if you're the problem and
you're just covering like yeah thanks
sam for this code or if sam was like yo
i wrote a bloom shader just for you
because you're my best friend
here you go ah the shameless the
shamelessness you know would have been
fine if sam was like you know
thanks cherno for this code let's just
quickly add a little pull request to
just have this in here well what can i
say bloom
fairly well done
i think it's i think the bloom part is
probably the strongest part of your
engine and i mean even though i'm kind
of saying that jokingly i'm also not
because obviously like this is a good
way to do bloom like it's going through
compute chad as it's doing quite a lot
of passes and all of that stuff as
opposed to you know the rest of the code
which is just like
um you know all inside the window class
and doing you know who knows what now i
will also since we're looking at shaders
let's quickly take a look at some of the
other stuff i'm kind of interested in
your main shader which i guess is what
default shader so this is kind of like
the pbr shader um
which uh yeah see this looks quite
different from my code i think so it's a
little bit better okay so we're doing
like pcr like the shadows did look
pretty nice it's hard to tell obviously
but the shadows did look decent looks
like you're using pcf filtering for that
stuff and so i assume that you have some
kind of
uh array with like pcf like you know
with the actual like
noise values or maybe that's what you
were using the noise texture for because
obviously it has to be somewhat
randomized
in order to do that but this is just
fairly like
basic fairly like standard
uh boilerplate kind of pbr code
uh with obviously like your fresnel
fresnel schlick
and all that stuff here so because this
is like an actual reflection
i assume this is like some kind of
specular term so this is actually like
basically simulating like a crude
reflection
um
whereas this code over here
which is taking the ambient term from
like
the normal
uh at lord 10 specifically so this is
like the irradiance i guess so you
probably don't have an irradiance map
and you're just simulating your radiance
by taking the tenth uh mip from this
that's kind of your ambient term there
and then that's being eventually
multiplied on
so that's our ambient light that's our
direct light along with like that
specular reflection uh and yeah that's
pretty much it and then we also output
the normal over here obviously and then
we have this loc thing which is the
viewfrag position so this is like the
view space position i guess
which looks like it pretty much okay it
comes in from the vertex shadow okay
cool and this stuff is probably going to
be used inside the
uh ssao shader so we take in those three
textures over here screen texture plus
orientation normal and uh well no noise
texture but these these two kind of give
us our data that we need to actually
this basically just calculates like the
level of occlusion based on how close we
are to other geometry uh and then that's
what obviously uh gives us that kind of
darkening that we see and yeah i mean
really obviously really simple ssao
itself which this looks like pretty much
the most primitive form of it is a
really simple algorithm and it works
pretty well it has a lot of problems and
there's a lot of better solutions but
this is actually like for what you get
bang for buck this is uh definitely a
pretty good algorithm anyway that's
pretty much tying up i think this code
review overall well done bloom shader is
sus as usual thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoyed this code review let me
know what you thought in the comments
section below if you would do stuff
differently let me know what you thought
of the c sharp cutter if you thought i'd
try something new today if you want me
to take a look at your code next time
then send it in to codereview gmail.com
that email address and some instructions
will be in the description below if you
are interested in the technical side of
things that you see in these code
reviews and you want to get better at
like algorithms and all of that stuff
then definitely check out brilliant
using my link in the description below i
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you